good morning ladies and gentlemen I'm
David yazi director of the 92nd Street
wise Underberg poetry Center and I'd
like to welcome you to the final talk in
our series of sunday morning lectures
entitled biographers and brunch we are
pleased today to welcome Fred Kaplan
whose previous books include biographies
of gore Vidal Henry James
Charles Dickens and Thomas Carlyle this
morning he will speak to us about the
life and work of Mark Twain for those of
you joining us for the first time I
might say a word about format mr. Kaplan
will speak for approximately 50 minutes
after which he will respond to 10 or 15
minutes of questions from the audience
this morning we are pleased to have with
us c-span who will be taping mr.
Kaplan's talk for broadcast if you have
a question for mr. Kaplan at the end of
the hour please wait for a microphone to
be brought to you before asking your
question following this we will adjourn
for a light brunch served just outside
this is where you will find copies of
mr. Kaplan's book the singular Mark
Twain on sale as well I wanted to remind
you that the next event in our critics
and brunch series will take place on
Sunday March 28th when Benjamin harsh
off will speak to us about the work of
the painter Marc Chagall you'll also be
interested to know that plans are
already underway for next season's
biographers in brunch series beginning
in the fall talks under consideration
include James Gibbons on Isaac Bashevis
singer Jay Perini on William Faulkner
Edward Mendelsohn on WH Auden John Simon
on Bernard Shaw Stephen Greenblatt on
Shakespeare and lucasta Miller on the
Bronte's
I hope you will join us as Fred Kaplan
tells us in his remarkable new biography
of Mark Twain Twain enjoyed meeting
writers whom he admired one such meeting
took place here in New York City in 1888
when Twain passed several hours on a
park bench in Washington Square with
Robert Louis Stevenson Stevenson had
written to Twain a mash No
a fan letter that sheds I think certain
light on the difficulties of Twain's
reputation even today the physically
frail Stevenson who had sat for a number
of portraits with the expatriate
American painter John Singer Sargent
wrote to Twain as follows My dear Mark
Twain I should have written a great
while ago to the author of Huckleberry
Finn a book which I have read four times
and I'm quite ready to begin again
tomorrow I think you will like to hear
this I got huckleberry when I was pretty
ill read it straight through began at
the beginning and read it straight
through again without a break just at
this juncture down comes a distinguished
painter Sargent to do my portrait
he was very refined and privately French
and when I insisted that huckleberry was
to be read along aloud at my sittings he
wilted sir but I told him he had to face
it and he did and I believe it did him
good
I think he's supposed I should have had
Baudelaire read aloud to me despite
Twain's love-hate relationship with the
United States his work is
quintessentially American in a way that
drove the very refined and privately
French singer to distraction when we
think of Twain we think immediately of
the folksy humorist and rivaled
raconteur for example his dinner talk
entitled some thoughts on the science of
onanism as Fred Kaplan puts it Twain was
seen by a number of his contemporaries
as quote a vulgar plebeian without
education manners or tastes Twain
himself only had a mild argument with
that view mr. Kaplan adds but Twain was
also a supreme artist as Ernest
Hemingway said all modern literature
comes from one book by Mark Twain called
Huckleberry Finn it is one of the great
achievements of Fred Kaplan's biography
that he's able to show all of the sides
of Twain the whole Twain with his many
contradictions brought into illuminating
relationship
even unity mr. Kaplan has been a
finalist for the Pulitzer Prize and the
National Book Critics Circle Award and
I'm delighted that he could be with us
today
please welcome Fred Kaplan thank you for
that elegant introduction and thank you
for the applause it's nice to be
applauded for doing something I enjoy
doing which is the writing biography and
happening opportunity to talk to you
about biography about great literary
figures and about literature
Mark Twain as you probably well know of
course was a novelist a travel writer an
essayist a lecturer he crammed a whole
world of literary and non-literary
activities into his very rich and
resonant life
he also wrote Maxim's some of them most
of them are quite caustic you know about
his his satiric and his very tart tongue
some of the caustic Maxim's are also
humorous and a few of them are very
appropriate for the political season
that we have already rather fully
entered into everybody's private motto
it's better to be popular than write
patriot the person who can holler the
loudest without knowing what he's
hollering about
some of the Maxim's have have a
melancholy if not pessimistic tone to
them especially more so as Twain got
into the latter stages of his life which
like I suppose many Yuma rests we can
think of Charlie Chaplin and others were
not personally happy years for him and
in fact increasingly gloomy both in his
personal life and and his vision of what
life is all about what what the universe
is who is responsible for someone like
Mark Twain and for the rest of us who is
to blame for this sad mess and so so one
of them that I picked out as appropriate
to someone of my age
not-not-not to the to the younger people
here in in the audience but someone of
my age can certainly appreciate this one
there there is no sadder sight than a
young pessimist except an old optimist
one of my favorites is good advice for
all of us but especially for a lecturer
always acknowledge a fault frankly this
will throw those in authority off their
guard and give you the opportunity to
commit more well if I were to begin to
acknowledge all my faults as a writer so
biographers a lecturer there wouldn't be
time for a lecture this morning
fortunately I am going to be self
protective and not talk to you about my
faults as elektra but talk to you about
that wonderful far from faultless but
extraordinary day resident writer who we
know as Mark Twain he was of course
named Samuel Langhorne Clemens at his
birth I was born November 30th 1835 he
became Mark Twain in 1863 when he chose
that name
it's a has a very resonant ring to us
now but Mark Twain as you know was a
pseudonym that puzzled people initially
literary histories made much of that
student in Mark Twain biographers and
psychological critics have found
significance in a man who when creating
an alternate self calls himself Twain
the the the the notion of Twain nests in
the sense of duplication particularly in
the sense of doubles was something that
Twain had some anticipation perhaps when
he took that student as a pseudonym in
1863 would reverberate through his life
and through his writings the issue of 1
versus 2 of twins of a light twin of a
dark twin of a good twin of a bad twin
of
white of black suffuses his life in his
writing career his family he was always
Sam or Samuel and occasionally his wife
used a pet name for him that was hers
alone the family called him papa
which as a good Victorian patriarch that
side of Twain that was as conventional
as we associate with a Victorian
patriarchal figure enjoyed being called
Papa but his life had
special name for him she called him
youth which was both a a loving
endearment that referred to how he was
when she first met him and when they
fell in love it was also a loving
endearment that referred to his
irrepressible 'ti is a mercurial figure
he found it so difficult to sit still he
was ever Restless and and mercurial also
in the sense that he thought that the
essence of the totality of unity was
doubleness
and inconsistency and the right to
change one's mind at the snap of the
fingers of the flash of a mental synapse
the world youth when his wife Livi used
it it was also sometimes a gentle
sometimes a slightly sharper reminder to
him that on this particular occasion it
was about time that he acted like a
grown-up but he acted like an adult he
is an extraordinary exemplification of
the joyousness but also the danger of a
lifelong adolescent behavior genius has
a special dispensation in that regard I
could get away with little to nothing
from my deeply cherished wife and from
my family and friends of the kind of
thing that Twain got away with he got
away with it partly because he himself
was extraordinarily resilient inwardly
in regard to exterior external comment
remark what people thought of him he had
a powerful self protectiveness that is
is a wonder to behold something I admire
immensely on the one hand he was
sensitive to slights
as thinnest skin as any one of us has in
regard to sensitivity from childhood on
but at the same time he had this
extraordinary inner defensive capacity
to to ward off slights criticisms
put-downs of almost every kind and he
did it through the marvelous gift of
creative anger he knew had to be angry
he knew had he knew how to to in
self-defense attack others it's a very
hard lesson of course for most of us to
learn since we're brought up in a
culture in society in which we're
premium is put on a listening carefully
to other people's criticism it may be
benefiting from it a premium is put upon
being a good person who controls oneself
in in in public and in personal
relationships and doesn't doesn't add
Tempest additional tempest to the small
teapots between was the tempestuous and
tempest creating person and on every
level and in every aspect of his life
and it was a marvelous defensive
strategy or weapon that he gave no
thought to it wasn't an intellectual
strategy at all he didn't have a
therapist tea he didn't discuss these
matters about how we should handle this
and that situation or what he should do
with this relationship no he he he was
in all these things instinctively
self-confident to the extent that he
allowed himself to be himself for better
and for worse most often it was for the
better for himself and even for the
better for lots of other people and for
the world occasionally it was quite
damaging to himself and to other people
well
macht Wayne is singular in three senses
one he's a unique figure in American
literature who looms above all the
others as the most wild widely quoted
and recognized
he's always envisioned as the
quintessential writer the quintessential
American writer of course and his
unified is singular in the sense that
the writer and the man despite the two
names are a unified personality there is
a an advantage to to think of Twain as
mr. Clemens and mr. Twain as one of my
most very admired predecessors in Twain
biography it did there's an advantage in
seeing him as a split personality in
which mr. Clemens is the patriarchal and
conventional Victorian and mr. Twain is
the iconoclastic artistic writer but
this is also an important advantage I
think in trying to see him as a totality
the same kind of different in his
particular eyes duay different in his
genius but the same kind of totality of
unified personality in essence that each
one of us as is as an individual I I
don't take the postmodernist approach
that says there's nothing there there is
no personality in the sense of there is
no unity or singular self we are all
floating atoms of different kinds of
particularity in which self hood is a
intellectual and a psychological fiction
no I think self hood is a real thing
it's sometimes fragmented and sometimes
inconsistent it's sometimes difficult to
get a handle on
and when you get a handle on it it's not
likely to result in some kind of
rational and logical niek package of
human explanation of that particular
human being no it it's it's complicated
and messy
Unity's in in his literary works
Mark Twain had his fingers on the pulse
speed of who we are and who we were and
made that available to us in ways that
make it possible to say as a metaphor
that Mark Twain wrote aspects of America
into existence of course it would still
be there if Mark Twain had never existed
but it would stand in our minds in a
different way he changed our view of
ourselves and there's an entity called
Mark Twain's America whether we use the
phrase or not that America is one that
we recognize as ours
even in the 21st century and images from
Twain's literary works helped us to see
it Tom Sawyer life on the Mississippi
and the Gilded Age frame the issues of
the country versus the city of the
change from an idealistic aesthetically
attractive pastoral Jeffersonian America
to the post-civil war urbanized and
industrialized corrupt materialistic
long political campaign seasons
president doesn't stay home on the porch
and wait for just people to come by and
interview him but he's out there on the
hustings the world that that we know of
course Mark Twain in his literary works
both gave to us an anticipation of
and yet also gave us a way to position
ourselves in terms of the small-town
American pastor a life that he
especially embodied and that sticks so
vividly in our minds in Tom Sawyer and
in Huck Finn and in life on the
Mississippi especially and the images
that we have that are associated on
stage screen television with Hannibal
Missouri in roughing it
his second travel book he provided a
sort of read if you will for America's
preoccupation with East versus West with
the East Coast versus the west coast
with a civilized some would say a feat I
wouldn't new york city brunch crowd and
the rugged outdoor life of people who
work and play in the Sierras and other
places where a different image sartorial
and otherwise applies he also in his
literary works as you know and this is a
motif that runs throughout his life
emphasized a standard 19th century theme
with his own twist and that is the
contrast between materialism and
idealism between between the
satisfaction of the Updike Ian world of
hard material everyday objects the
thickness of everyday life as Updike
says Anna marvellous short story Plato
was wrong and trained basically agreed
that Plato was wrong on the other hand
his he was keenly aware that the
materialism that he himself felt so
strongly and that drove a lot of his
life
the desire for example to be a rich man
not all that usual in a right and we
think of as a serious literary figure
quite unusual in fact was a drive in a
context in which he was aware that that
he he lost he forfeited certain
consolations and a certain kind of
traditional value system in his in his
drive to to enjoy the good things of
this world and to to eventually be the
richest writer who ever lived
he also was very very much an epitome of
another aspect of nineteenth-century
America and of 20th the 21st century
America and and that was the can-do
aspect of Twain's mentality and it took
in his case the various forms one that's
most striking and again very unusual in
a writer is that he was fascinated by
inventions and he himself felt that he
had a knack for seeing technical what
what technologically what the future
required and in and in a small way
invented a number of things himself only
one of which ever made him any money and
a small amount of it indeed he is the
progenitor of what he called the self
pasting scrapbook
so in in the 1860s and 70s if you had
photos that you wanted to save what did
you do with them well you put them in a
scrapbook but you had the challenge of
how to attach your photograph to the
page Twain created a self pasting
scrapbook in which the the the the the
holding material was connected to the
page itself it was it was embedded in
the page in chemical form well you don't
think of Twain doing something like that
he also invented suspenders no he wasn't
the first person to invent suspenders
but he invented an improved form of
suspenders which were rather awkward and
and didn't really catch on it would have
it turned out they were extremely
Ottawa's extremely awkward for a man to
use these suspenders in any public
bathroom situation I think I don't never
call suspenders indeed yes they were
called suspenders but he has he had a
particular name for them that he used
for the marketing aspect of this Twain
as a businessman is a wonderful topic in
and of itself and I'm just touching on
it briefly in passing because these two
inventions that I've referred to which
came out of his own mind are only the
tip of the iceberg in regard to his
fascination with technology and his
desire to be a sort of visionary
businessman who would come up with ideas
or recognize other people's ideas and
then get financial backing for for
manufacturing whatever the item happened
to be and then benefiting from being a
major owner or shareholder royalty
holder in the invent
and so on the most the best-known of
these inventions which is quite
appropriate for Twain was called the
page typesetter
and this brought together his
fascination with with words as a writer
and with the production of vehicles
books if you will
magazines newspapers that would that
would disseminate the written word and
as cost-effective and and as sales
directed way as possible using the
latest technology so between like all
bad businessmen and bad investors I
don't know how you did with the latest
stock market bubble was filled with
eternal optimism about his fortune being
just around the corner and was
constantly looking at the ticker so to
speak or the stock quotations to see
what he was up or down for the day he
was constantly doing rosy figures in his
extensive notebooks since he was a
compulsive rider he had to keep
compulsive notes about his business
activities and in doing so he would cast
projections about sales for the
typesetter and for other inventions that
he estimated and with such a rosy
colored glasses and without awareness of
what apparently so I've been told by
experts as its kind of a general
guideline in regard to investing and
inventions don't invest in invention
till it is already successfully marketed
because you'll probably lose your shirt
well Twain kept a few shirts but he lost
a great great deal
money and it had a grievous effect on
his life I'm using the typesetter as an
example of one of numbers of such
inventions and it also stands the
enforced stock market in investments
most of which turned out to be worth
much less in the end when he needed to
sell them than what he had bought them
for and that one of the grievous results
was that train constantly was worried
about money even though he had a very
substantial well satisfactory I should
say income as a writer never enough to
suit his ego or his rather handsome if
not lavish style of life but still in
modern terms a very substantial amount
of money even though the arc of his
earning career was a downward one which
an awful lot of writers do experience
you start off with the big splash as
Twain did in the late 1860's with his
first travel book innocents abroad and
that becomes sort of the benchmark
against which to judge the success of
books thereafter and Twain never in his
lifetime even with the Adventures of
Huckleberry Finn life on the Mississippi
Tom Sawyer a Connecticut Yankee in King
Arthur's Court he never sold as many of
one title at the first publication as
his first book innocents abroad sold now
you can understand that that's a very
unpleasant frustrating ultimately
embittering feeling experience for a
writer to have well the he if he had
stuck just as income from writing he
would have been economically fine
but indeed eventually the stock market
investments and especially the the
inventions the page typesetter put him
in a state of what we would think of as
bankruptcy so by 1895 1896 actually by
that by 1890 1890 1891
he was and he was desperate for money
and he needed to retrench considerably
which brings us to another aspect of
Twain's career that relates to this
topic of Twain is businessman between
was also a businessman in an activity
much closer to to his writing career
than the other business activities I've
been talking about Twain from very early
on in his career earned at first a
modest amount and substantial amounts of
money from lecturing from going around
on in an American which there's no radio
no television in which all entertainment
is live and in which there was a thirst
and a hunger all over the country more
or less but it's quite substantial for
for for information for ideas for
illumination for elevation and here we
are in the night 92nd Street Y which is
a a institution that exists that ties
into and that comes out of this long
history in American culture of public
education of adult education of putting
tremendous emphasis upon the value that
information knowledge insight has in
everyday life
for the force civil life as a whole for
the community if you will for the
progress of the culture Twain plugged
himself in to this as numbers of other
writers did mostly in his persona as a
humorist and from the first his first
public presence on the stage and the mid
1860s in 1864 in San Francisco when he
was a nervous and hesitant speaker with
a great deal of stage fright he
gradually over the years became an
immensely polished public performer so
if you think Hal Holbrook is good should
have seen Twain well I didn't see Twain
either but but by all accounts he was
superb at it however the other side of
the coin is he didn't like it to begin
with and he gradually grew to hate it
they gradually grew to detest public
lecturing for multiple reasons including
the travel that was involved no
airplanes of course and dirty noisy
smoke belching trains taking one up and
down the East Coast into Chicago and
other places he hated the separation
from his family he hated the the
repetitiveness of it because all public
performers of that sort who were on a
circuit electro circuit and acting
circuit or what-have-you
even though they they do their best to
look freshen and bright and new at each
performance inwardly a part of them
knows more or less that this is a
mechanical repetition of things that
they've done before especially when
they're reading from a script' I'm not
reading from a script' mostly because I
don't want to bore myself and I don't
want to feel that sense of repetition
and and and so forth so but Twain did in
a sense read from a screen
but he read from it the way a
professional performer does he memorized
every word of the selections from his
literary works that he edited down for
oral performance to make them smoother
for oral performance but he most came to
hate it because he had to do it he felt
because he needed the money and he
increasingly had to do it because of his
business failure is combined with you
know the fairly lavish style of life
that he lived by the early 1890s with
the failure of the page typesetter he
lost a great great deal of money had
huge debts he realized one that economic
reasons he might be better off living
someplace else say in Europe rather than
in his handsome Hartford mansion if you
will and he also by 1895 96 realized
that he had to go back on the lecture
stage and traveled in 1895 around the
world literally around the world this
world-famous writer
travelling around the world going from
west coast to the to Hawaii to to to
Asia to Malaysia to India to South
Africa taking notes for a travel book
the last one he ever wrote calling in
which he takes the title from the
equator going around the equator and
then ending up in England where the
proceeds from the lecture tour enabled
him to pay off a lot of bills and then
he sat down to write a book that he that
all his insides rebelled against writing
it was a terrible time in his life among
other reasons
when they returned when they when they
arrived in England in the spring late
spring of 1896 they got the news from
back in Hartford that their eldest
deeply loved daughter Susan Suzy had
died of meningitis a bacterial form of
meningitis that was virtually
untreatable in those days it was
devastating to Susie's two sisters it
was just devastating to a father and it
came close to destroying the life of her
mother train and his wife had four
children
the first their only son died in infancy
Twain as was his want held himself
responsible for the death of the child
he was a great self blamer who then
would would use that to drive himself to
the opposite side of self praise and
then that combination and dynamic would
move the Twain engine forward
Suzy died in 1895 in 1896 leaving two
daughters alive and one of those two
daughter daughters died in 1909 one year
before 6 or 8 months before Twain
himself died so it was a even for the
Victorian world late nineteenth century
in which there's a very high death rate
in for children and families Twain felt
that his luck was not only bad but
somebody was after him now this brings
us to two things one the the issue of
somebody being after him
Twain Twain from his early childhood as
little Sam little Sammy Clemens had a
skeptical and probing mind he was aware
of and interested in local superstitions
in his world of Hannibal Missouri they
had an impact on him and he listened
very carefully to the the pronouncements
of the wise elders of his community
whether at home or in the churches
Baptist and Methodist that his mother
particularly took him to and from an
early age he developed sort of an
argument with God and he cast it in in
terms of the power of God versus the
power of Satan and decided early on that
that though God was referred to quite
frequently if any in the world of his
childhood and adolescence in in frontier
Missouri if you will in that Baptist and
Methodist world he decided from early on
that if some omniscient power existed
and it was generally cast in terms of
God and God versus the devil the things
that God did and the things that he was
told as a boy he had a watch out for and
avoid doing which all seemed to him so
natural and normal and because he was
told not to do them they seem so much
compelling and exciting and and tempting
the things that God told him not to do
and the performances that that God
required and demanded increasingly
seemed to him as if
then they were really things that the
devil ought to be doing and to be in
charge of so that all the things that
increasingly were he became aware were
referred to as the things that God
commanded that God said that that God
approved of and so on were really an
exemplification of the Toth the total
power of Satan rather than the and that
God was either an indifferent or casual
figure or he was powerless or really God
was a projection of Satan Satan was
essentially in charge now II didn't do
this in literalistic terms
fundamentalist literalistic terms no
that's those are the terms
he started with he transformed this
gradually into and projected it on to
the level of human psychology and human
nature human society human relations and
the question of what is our condition
here in the universe in his good moods
he has a touch of what we think of as
traditional deism the count of deer the
deism associated with the founding
fathers there's a god up there someplace
but he's really fairly indifferent to
human activity and we go our way
as best we can within the framework of
the limitations that we have but in his
bad moods and they as I said became they
became more and more frequent as he grew
older and they more and more came to
dominate his literary persona as his
writings certainly from from Pudd'nhead
Wilson and a Connecticut
on to the mysterious stranger
manuscripts and so many short stories
and so on in his bad mood it seemed to
him this universe was a random place and
if there is a God and this is from a
letter he wrote in 1904 this is a God
who has no morals yet blandly sets
himself up as head to sunday-school
superintendent of the universe who has
no idea of mercy justice or honesty yet
obtusely imagines himself the inventor
of those things a human race that takes
him at his own valuation without
examining the statistics thinks itself
intelligent yet hasn't any more evidence
of it than had Jonathan Edwards a
colonial Calvinist New England preacher
in his wildest moments a race and now
he's talking about human beings because
this is the connected to his vision of
this being a godless at the universe in
which things happen that wouldn't happen
if there were a moral God in the
universe a race human race which did not
make itself or it's vicious nature yet
quaintly holds itself responsible for
its acts the one hand we have the image
in our mind of course of the mark twain
of pastoral Jacksonian pre-civil war
America of Hannibal Missouri of the st.
Petersburg of Tom Sawyer's on the other
hand Twain who did attempt somewhat
successfully to downplay the increasing
strength of this dark side of him
especially concerned later in life
sales started many many manuscripts many
many stories and novels that exemplify
this view of God and of the randomness
of life and never finished them put them
aside on the shelf he couldn't bear to
go on or you felt what's the point if my
readers read this they're not gonna look
at me anymore as the great embodiment of
American pastoral and rural sunshine of
how quaint it is and cute it is to be
Tom Sawyer etc so a tween who who is
both and and mostly in the American
popular imagination that popular
idealistic sunshine a Tom Sawyer ish
Hannibal Missouri Twain but a Twain on
the other hand on the other side who
sees this universe is in random and a
dark place without a God who cares for
us little known loves us who has any
interest in us at all if that God exists
and also concomitant with that a
universe in which all human and every
other action or activity is determined
and in which free will is non-existent
that's not a cheerful view of life is it
and we all juggle all sorts of balls if
you will on the one hand to take
responsibility for our lives and to
generate good things in our lives by
taking responsibility for our lives on
the other hand we juggle that other ball
that says well you know what could have
prevented this who could have stopped us
what better could I haven't done
I had only bad choices to make and
anyway who can see the future
I thought I made the best possible
choice and awful look what's happened
that kind of thing so Twain late in his
life talked about to his friends and
wrote about and letters and wrote in
private manners
that we're really if ever published in
his lifetime wrote about determinism and
in fact wrote a book in question and
answer form in dialogue form called what
is man in which he in effect says that
we are all the inevitable and determined
products of things that have happened
before
the atomic level or the molecular level
on the biome the cellular biological
genetic level and so what are we going
around flailing ourselves for beating
ourselves up for he says here in this
letter and many other places we we are
overly prideful and misunderstanding of
ourselves when we go about holding
ourselves responsible for even the bad
things that we do is something anomic
about that lawless about that and and
yet at the same time of course it's it's
it's it has its own sort of compelling
logic the irreversibility of the next
moment as it is the product of all the
things that have happened in previous
moments to go to that second item that
that I was referring to before and that
you've probably blessedly long forgotten
that there was going to be a second item
and in regard to Twain as business man
why why he hated lecturing and I
mentioned that he hated lecturing also
because he felt constrained he felt
forced to do it and he went so far to
use a word very powerful in his own
contemporary environment from childhood
on he referred to
the need to lecturer as slavery not even
a form of slavery but as as slavery
itself he was he was a genius with a
creative exaggeration but the issue of
slavery and race has been a substantial
one in Twain's life and in and and it
has been in Twain's literary and
cultural inheritance he began with
genuine sympathy for an immense
curiosity about the slaves of his pre
Civil War border state Missouri world
but he accepted slavery as simply the
way things were like most pre Civil War
southerners of otherwise liberal feeling
he didn't say what he had not been
signaled to say well think about the
Civil War changed all that and so did
his developing maturity in the 1860s and
the 1870s he became increasingly a voice
that denounced injustice as a reporter
in San Francisco in the 1860s he made
himself popular by protesting against
and satirizing the official and the
unofficial mistreatment of the Chinese
especially by the San Francisco Police
Force which was predominantly Irish by
the early 1880s he had come to the
realization that the clause of the
Declaration of Independence that says
all men are created equal means just
that there are no exceptions that he had
admired many of the blacks of his
childhood world had helped him to see
blacks as human beings by the late 1880s
he helped support college education and
law school education
Yale for number of black young men and
he actually a favorite reparations a hot
topic today is those of you who read
yesterday's times saw in regard to the
statement by the president of Brown
University of Lac woman who has looked
who has established a committee to look
into the degree to which Brown
University benefited pre Civil War in
its foundation from money earned from
slavery the slave trade and cotton and
so on no single event in Twain's life
provided revelation and trained in this
regard it was a gradual a creative
process and August 1909 he wrote a
letter to a friend abroad and and placed
it on the on the the the table in the
foyer for his we're letters were put to
be mailed and his daughter Jean was to
take the letters to the post office and
she he had left the letter open
he had the envelope open and Jean when
she returned read the letter the entire
family was always concerned about oh my
god what is Papa saying now you know and
she brought it back to him and said that
he must open and change something in
that letter well Jean what must I change
you have said the Virgin Mary was not
white very well where's the harm why
it's shocking you numbskull what is
there about it that's shocking
can't you see Papa the idea of saying
the mother of a savior was colored it's
sacrilegious say Oh nonsense Jean
in hard day the population of the globe
was not more than a thousand millions
not one tenth of them were white what
does that fact suggest to you I I don't
know what does it suggest Papa it most
powerfully suggests that white was not a
favorite complexion with God has it
since become a favorite complexion with
him
no the population of the globe is now
one hundred fifteen hundred millions one
thousand and six millions of those
people are colored two thirds you see of
the human race there was not a white
person in Nazareth when I was there
except a foreign priest the people were
very dark don't you suppose they are
descendants of Mary's townsman of course
they are now what have you got to say
Jane well Jean responded I can't help it
Papa the idea of a colored mother of the
Savior is still revolting and you must
change it Twain was a Great Creator and
he helped create ourselves for ourselves
thank you
I been delighted to take questions and
there is a microphone I believe
available for the questioners and the
first question is up front so the
microphone is going to be at your side
in a second sir this is the one most
wonderful talk I've ever heard
on Mark Twain and much better than Hal
Holbrook much better than reading him
you flushed him out you made him real
three-dimensional deep down inside
psychological historical political thank
you for that but I I hope there's a but
I'm sorry there's a but but now there's
no idle idle
Nigel I didn't our sport but I have some
you brought out some connect connections
that I have one is my mother was from
Missouri born in Missouri my father was
born in Colorado I spent a lot of time
in the West in Montana and but all of us
ended up in New York City where I was
born but I I'm a physician and I was
specialized in my life about three
things
sad sex and death and what comes between
sex and death is aging and so I was
interested I was called to a health
meeting the other day a public policy
meeting for the whole world and I saw a
title in the department of psychiatry on
onanism could you tell me his thoughts
on onanism yes Twain was astounded by
the sexual attitudes of his contemporary
world though he himself led a fairly
ordinary life in regard to sexual
activity
but it's the word ordinary that's K as
against the the artifice the
extraordinary artifice that the
Victorian world held up in regard to
sexual activity there's a good reason to
believe that he had premarital sexual
activity with women he joked were great
fun but he would never marry
he was patriarchal and sexist in all the
usual Victorian ways but in enlightened
ways and as a husband he was a loyal and
devoted husband on every level he
married an extraordinary woman in one of
his autobiographical fragments he he he
remarks that every Protestant boy is
brought up to believe that the most
natural thing in the world is unnatural
masturbation onanism of course is a
biblically derived word from a minor Old
Testament figure Onan who spilled his
seed on the ground a very bad thing to
do in the Old Testament world and still
very problematic thing to do depending
on the time and the place in our
contemporary world and especially the
circumstances who is this what is this a
monistic statement about I'm sure is
often the issue not the physical actors
itself but what about so when he was a
resident in Paris in his adult life
middle adult life Twain made an
appearance before a group of American
residents in Paris called the stomach
Club one can only assume that they ate
very well continuously drank well and
to say anything about onanism but his
talk was on onanism which was a comic
talk filled with all sorts of phallic
references to this all-male group he
would never think of talking along those
lines if there any women in the audience
or in earshot at all it was it was it
was male after dinner
over your wine kind of conversation so
he was quite humorous about that but at
the same time it's a part of his his
general commitment to the the the
priority of of nature and the natural
life of the body and his tremendous
resistance to what he thought would
generally destructive the destructive
results of society religion government
what have you to interfere in our
private lives particularly our sexual
lives
what were his attitudes specifically
about the civil war and generally about
war well Mark Twain was a riverboat
twilit pilot before he became Mark Twain
between roughly 1857 in 1861 he doesn't
become Mark Twain until a few years
later when he's in Nevada and takes on
the pseudonym he was a riverboat pilot
making his living and it was a very
handsome living actually going up and
down from st. Louis to New Orleans with
cargo and freight in 18 in April of
course 1861 but much proceeding that
January February 1861 secession was
underway
South Carolina particularly taking the
glorious lead in asserting states rights
and Twain was not very engaged in
issues then but he was very worried
about his job and sure enough the sure
enough river traffic was closed Union
gunboats closed the river traffic at
Vicksburg and that was the end of this
very well-paying vocation that he had
worked his way up to from an apprentice
and what to do next well he was a son of
Missouri and so just in a sort of
nationalistic sense he thought he would
do something on behalf of the
Confederacy but he didn't feel much like
it and even though there was some slave
ownership in his family of a very
minimum a modest sort these were poor
people and and he he his family was not
pro-slavery and not anti-union they were
basically Pro Union but living there in
Missouri and in a part of Missouri where
everybody is raising the Confederate
flag there's a lot of pressure on him so
he he joined a group of Missouri militia
sort of from his home town in Hannibal
and there was sort of ragged and and
riding donkeys and had half-and-half
uniforms and it lasted just a few weeks
he hated every moment of it he said this
is crazy he didn't want to stay at home
at that home at that time was st. Louis
because the Union forces control st.
Louis and he felt they would come along
and draft him and make him be a pilot on
a union boat gunboat or what have you so
he sculpt and he hid and he what have
you and then his brother his elder
brother Orry and was appointed by the
Lincoln administration a patronage
appointment to the secretary ship of the
state of Nevada which was sort of the
number two position under the governor
himself and and both Sam and orient
thought it would be a good idea of Sam
went along because things were pretty
hot here in Missouri he didn't have
anything to do with this war if he could
help it
and he knew there was something out in
Nevada called the Mark Twain ledge and
that that ledge was rich with silver or
gold and other people were getting at
his ledge and he wanted it so he went
along with his brother and a to Nevada
and spent the war years in Nevada and in
California in the 1880s for a series on
the Civil War in 1885 for a series on
the Civil War that the century magazine
was publishing and they had all the
generals some votes many generals on
both sides and distinguished writing
about the war Twain responded yes I can
write you an essay about the war and it
was he called it a personal history of a
campaign that failed and it's a comic
satiric account of his few weeks of
misery discomfort and of his increasing
assessment that war is stupid
Warren's destructive it's the worst
thing that people can do and and that he
will come down firmly on the side of
exploding war into into smithereens by
satirically laughing at the stupidity of
the whole thing his favorite little
episode there was how his little group
almost met up with Ulysses as Grant who
was not yet of course the famous general
at cetera but was commanding a small
troop and there were he and his buddies
from Hannibal were terribly scared so
yes this a question up here she was next
possibly the reason that Mark Twain
didn't like to lecture was that he had
to take questions
I my question is about the end of
Huckleberry Finn it's it's really about
his views on slavery as you recall in
the you know toward the end of
Huckleberry Finn
Huck fails really cruelly to tell Jim
that he's really not being pursued as a
runaway slave and it leaves a very bad
taste in the in the mouths of the modern
viewer in any event and my question is
was this intentional was he saying
something about Huck Finn or was it
rather his own possibly his own slippage
into the feelings of the day that the
slave really didn't have feelings like
we do let me let me start to answer that
very interesting an off discussed issue
of the last third approximately of
Huckleberry Finn by saying in general
that Twain was a deeply flawed writer in
the sense that he had a genius for
illuminating vividly and memorably
individual moments and sequences and
settings and scenes and situations and
ideas and issues but he was very weak in
regard to totality and structure of
literary work and as his first
biographer Albert Bigelow Payne remarked
quite accurately composition in the
total sense was not his strong point so
every Twain novel and we tend to think
of him as a novelist but he came to
writing novels after he was already a
very successful travel writer he his
mind was not a mind that projected
itself into fictions as readily as a
professional novelist generally as say
Henry
Charles Dickens and and he was not was a
travel writer and essayist and a
novelist
in addition but a novelist in a sense
that his novels canakya King Arthur's
Court ventures Huckleberry Finn
Pudd'nhead Wilson all are deeply
structurally flawed they're not the kind
of perfectly put together kinds of
things he has a fascination for
digression and for filler and for taking
roundabout ways to get various places
the first two thirds of Huckleberry Finn
most readers and critics agreed it's
wonderfully tightly and brilliantly
structured it's as close as he ever got
to a perfect novel it's a great novel
but far from a perfect novel and it's
that last third of a novel that throws a
lot of modern readers especially if
modern readers are approaching it from
the aesthetic and structural point of
view they say hey what's happened here
this has really had pace and excitement
and suddenly it's gone static and we're
at the Phelps farm and Huck and this
wise guy Tom Sawyer who for whom whose
personal fictions are more important
than somebody else's inner well-being
are playing these games Huck is a little
conflicted about it playing these games
with Jim not telling him he's a he's a
prisoner and then doing all sorts of
kind of novelistic romance escape
adventure things as if the writing a TV
series a reality show here and there's
sort of you know tentatively scripting
it well for the madhuri to two things
the novel stops flat there it still got
wonderful little things in it here and
there but it stops flat there in terms
of building up drama and action but most
importantly it raises the question for
so many modern readers of of doesn't
wane as a writer understand that this is
morally repellant so as I said there's a
literature on
subject in various ways to try to
explain it away and none of them seem to
me totally successful I think to me the
explanation that most rings true is that
at that point where he began the Phelps
farm and the Jim as prisoner saying he
had run out of narrative ideas and and
that's not unusual for him you would get
so far and if in a story and just run
out of narrative ideas and put it aside
he had put aside Huckleberry Finn twice
before over a ten twelve year period and
in that summer of 1883 he was determined
to finish it and did I think he ran out
of narrative ideas I think that there
was some other issues in regard to how
to how his audience would accept and
deal with the inventions of Huckleberry
Finn with southern readers by it and
things of that sort that came up but it
is is a wonderful gift to us that it's
so badly flawed because you can ask the
question and and I can try my best but
not with any great success to to really
answer it in a way that's satisfactory
there are attempts to explain it oh it's
allegorical oh it deals with
reconstruction the reconstruction
post-civil war reconstruction period and
it's his way of showing us in miniature
that blacks are freed but they're not
really free you say because there's a
reconstruction they've gained civil
rights etc but they're still really in a
certain chains if you will Jim Crow is
developing on and on so a good question
I wish I could do better I know Mark
Twain was very influential in helping
General Grant write his memoirs did he
help anybody else's literary career and
also was he involved in any of the
social movements of his time like
women's suffrage and
the progressive movement of Jacob Riis
and yeah he he favored voting rights for
women he was not an active supporter in
a sense of devoting time and energy to
public advancement of rights for women
but he did express himself publicly
every now and then on that matter
referring back to his mother who me
Jane Lampton Clemens he wrote a
wonderful essay about a graphical essay
and whose intelligence and imagination
he deeply respected he was married
through an extraordinary woman his point
was why the hell are you letting me vote
and not these people if you've got to
make a choice they'll do better than I
will you know so that's um yes he he was
you know as a businessman and as a mind
very much a capitalist but he was
extremely interested in social movements
and and with transforming society making
it a better place he gave he put most of
his emphasis on John on the topic of the
issue of justice equal treatment for
people fair treatment for people
rational treatment for people and you
can especially see that in a Connecticut
Yankee in King Arthur's Court in which
Hank Morgan who gets banged on the head
and goes back to King Arthur's Court
tries to take all the the the the the
the the liberal ideas that Twain has as
a liberal Republican of Mugwump someone
who who wants progress and change in
late 19th century terms
Hank Morgan attempts to improve and
reform and make that King Arthur II in
society more like his world and it and
on every level especially the
technological level it turns out to be a
mess the one asked the one a political
activity and and and dramatic Center
Fort Wayne of a great deal of effort
private and public was the
spanish-american war which at first he
was in favor of he thought we ought to
get those autocratic authoritarian
medieval brutal Spaniards out of Cuba
and then he got a little uncomfortable
when he saw what the American armed
occupation was doing in Cuba and then by
the end of 1898 1899 1900 he was
absolutely revolted by the American war
in the Philippines and the occupation of
the Philippines and he against his own
self-interest because people who bought
Tom Sawyer and bought into that
idealistic pastoral vision didn't
necessarily want to hear their favorite
American iconic pastoral writer speaking
out strongly against a very popular war
in America extremely popular war but he
did and along with William James he
helped found and became one of the
offices of the anti-imperialist league
he had a strong sense of America going
down a wrong road beginning with the
spanish-american war a road that were
more or less still on today thank you